نبدا معك
اسماعيل نعم حقيقه في الساعات الاخيره
شمال قطاع غزه يشهد هدوء نسبيا في ظل
تحليق مكثف من طائرات الاحتلال واستمرار
اطلاق القذائف مدف قذائف مدفعيه من اليات
قوات الاحتلال باتجاه منطقه الصبره
وباتجاه منطقه الصناعه وجنوب حي الرمال
هذه المناطق التي تشهد قصفا عنيفا وفي ذات
الوقت ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه مع المقاومه
الف فلسطينيه قبل لحظات وصل الى مستشفى
المعمداني شهيد من منطقه حي الصبرا التي
تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال في المناطق
الغربيه الجنوبيه على هذه اطراف هذا الحي
حيث نصبت قناصتها وتقدم تقدمت الاليات الى
تلك النقطه في حين ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تستمر في المجابهه والاشتباكات العنيفه
والتصدي لاي محاوله تقدم لكن نتحدث عن
الحاله الانسانيه الصعبه التي وصل اليها
شمال قطاع غزه حاله من التجويع وحاله من
نقص الموارد الاساسيه وحاله من عدم ومنع
قوات الاحتلال من دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى شمال القطاع ايام طويله تمر
دون دخول اي من المساعدات في حين ان شمال
قطاع غزه يعاني وهو باحتياج كبير جدا الى
المواد الغذائيه والمواد التموينيه
والمساعدات الانسانيه حتى على مستوى
القطاعات المختلفه سواء قطاع البلديات او
القطاع الصحي او حتى القطاع الانساني او
القطاع البشري هذه كلها بحاجه الى مساعدات
انسانيه اليوم فقدت العائلات في شمال قطاع
غزه ماده الارز التي كانت هي الماده
الرئيسيه لتغذيه معظم سكان شمال القطاع
اليوم اصبحت كافه الموارد الاساسيه من
المواد التموينيه هي مفقوده في ظل ايضا
نظره هذه المواد تشهد مناطق شمال قطاع غزه
ارتفاع كبير للاسعار وبذات الوقت تشهد
ايضا احتياجا مالي وسيوله اح ماليه كبيره
في ظل اغلاق قوات الاحتلال البنوك
المتواجده في شمال قطاع غزه السيوله
مفقوده وايضا المواد الغذائيه مفقوده وفي
حين ايضا العلاج اصبح امنيه الكثير من
العائلات بعد ان خرج مستشفى الشفاء عن
الخدمه ما وحاصرت قوات الاحتلال الجوانب
الغربيه الجنوبيه من هذا المستشفى نعم
شكرا اسماعيل اليا